The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to
talk about two things,
maybe, depending on
the level of interest.
We can talk a little bit
about PSET five and the things
that I think are weird in
the coding part of PSET five.
By the way, how many
people started PSET five?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I downloaded it.
PROFESSOR: Hmm, maybe we are not
going to talk about P set five.
You guys need to start early!
AUDIENCE: I did.
PROFESSOR: You did.
Yeah.
I guess I can't punish
you for everyone else.
So P set five, and I
can talk about graphs.
I can talk about whatever
didn't make sense in class
and I can talk about
background stuff for graphs.
So how do people feel?
Who wants talk about the
PSET that we haven't read?
[LAUGHTER]
Who wants to talk about graphs?
AUDIENCE: It's really easy.
We took 604 two.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if you took
604 two, nothing here is new.
I mean nothing in the
recitation is new.
We're going to take it to new
heights of graph knowledge,
and you'll be able to
do many more cool things
that you're able to do before.
OK, so PSET.
For people who
started early, what
was the gist of the
coding assignments?
AUDIENCE: So we have
to speed up something.
When I ran the tests-- do I
say what I got as results?
PROFESSOR: The time isn't on
the PSET so you can say what you
got as --
AUDIENCE: Pardon?
PROFESSOR: The time
isn't on the PSET
so you can say what
you got as a time.
AUDIENCE: OK, the slowest
was like add for me.
PROFESSOR: You should look
to see add is a valid answer.
Look at the questions and
see if add is a valid answer.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: It's not like what
was lowest function, right?
There's more text there.
You should read the
rest of the text
and see if add makes
sense as a valid answer.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
OK.
PROFESSOR: What you're
doing-- big picture--
is you have some processor,
that's not a real processor,
and it can do arithmetic
with bytes and 16-bit words.
And we give you the
basic operations
and then they give you a library
for large number arithmetic
because, guess what?
16 bytes addition, subtraction?
Not going to cut it for
science applications
are for cryptography,
what we want to play with.
What are the basic operations
that that processor can do?
Front of the PSET,
so even if you
didn't get to the
coding assignment
you can still tell me.
AUDIENCE: Divide,
and zeros, I think.
Zeros.
PROFESSOR: Plus, minus,
multiply, divide, and mod.
Let's start to these.
So you have two primitives
in that processor.
You have have bytes, which
are basically 8-bit digits.
There's 200.
The range is 0 to 256.
And the word is 16-bit,
from 0 to the 16 minus 1.
If you care to know
this is 6, 5, 5, 3, 5.
So, if you take two bytes
and add them together what do
you get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Not right.
It's a trick question.
You get word.
The processor cannot do
simple math on bytes.
It converts them up to words and
all the math happens on words.
Now if you guess two words,
and add them up together
what do you get?
AUDIENCE: Two words?
PROFESSOR: You do if
we're not that nice.
AUDIENCE: A world in carry bit?
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
you just get word.
At least nobody said a byte.
I was like, please don't say
byte, please don't say byte.
You said carry bit.
Why do we care
about the carry bit?
What is the problem if
you do addition this way?
AUDIENCE: If you're
going too high.
If the highest bit is
one on both of them.
Then it's like
overflow, kind of.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Suppose we're trying to add
2 to the 16 minus 1 plus 2
to the 16 minus 1.
By the way, does anyone
remember hex notation?
Hexadecimal?
OK, people who started
the PSET remember.
That's good.
It will be easy to write
things hex for the PSET.
If you try to add these numbers
you're going to get 1, F, F, F,
E. You can use the
math here to see
that this is more
than the words.
So you would like to know that
this thing overflows, right?
You like to know that there is.
Well we don't give you that.
All you get to this.
So addition happens,
modulo 2 to the 16.
If you want to be able to detect
overflow what they have to do?
AUDIENCE: Just tests those bits.
PROFESSOR: That one
way of doing it.
It would take quite a
few instructions, though.
If you want to do
overflow detection,
the easiest way I think of
doing it this to use this form.
So suppose you have two bytes.
This is the maximum
value in a byte, right?
255, 2 to the 8 minus 1.
If you have 2 bytes and
you add them all together
you're going to
get 1, F, E. Right?
It's just like the case here,
except you have a fewer F's.
Where is the carry here?
AUDIENCE: Could be the 1, right?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
This guy here is the carry
and this guy's the low result.
Does anyone know how
these are called?
If you have a word and
you have two bytes, what
is the first byte, what
is the second bytes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Most
significant byte,
M, S, B, and least
L, S, B. If you want to
figure out your carries,
then you should do
your math this way.
You're going to have
byte 1 plus byte 2.
Add them together.
And then you call L, S,
B to get the byte result.
And then you call M,
S, B to get the carry.
This is addition.
Everyone with me so far?
By the way, are these
numbers signed or unsigned?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: No negative
numbers, right?
So no support for
negative numbers.
Everything is going
to be positive.
And we're going to
build everything
we need off of positive
numbers because they're
easier to deal with.
What if I have two words
and I subtract them?
What do I get?
AUDIENCE: Word.
PROFESSOR: OK.
What if I have 0 minus 1?
What do I get?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
AUDIENCE: If you're
not using signs?
Do you get O, 1?
PROFESSOR: O, 1's, OK.
AUDIENCE: Ya.
Wait--
PROFESSOR: So, O 1's
would be this, F, F, F, F.
AUDIENCE: That's assuming
if you signed then.
It will overflow.
That's a really big number then.
PROFESSOR: So fancy
CS, 2's complement.
For people who think in
math mode, what is this?
AUDIENCE: I think.
PROFESSOR: It's minus
1 mod 2 to the 16.
Remember, when we were doing
modular arithmetic before,
to figure out a number's
multiplicative inverse?
And when we were
doing rolling hashes?
We didn't want negative numbers.
We made them positive.
So minus 1 lot to the
16 is 2 to the 16.
Minus 1, and comes
out to this value.
So you get minus 1,
it's just that you
have to know your basis.
So we got the addition
and subtraction.
Let's talk about multiplication.
What do you do for
multiplication?
What can you multiply?
Two bytes, very good.
Just two bytes.
What do you get?
A word.
Thank you.
You multiply two
bytes, you get a word.
What if there's overflow?
It's a trick question.
AUDIENCE: There's no overflow.
PROFESSOR: There is no overflow.
So two bytes, 2 to the
eighth minus 1 times 2
to the eighth minus 1,
is 2 to the 16 minus 2
to the 8th minus 2
to the eighth plus 1.
You can say this safely without
doing the arithmetic, right?
This is how much you can
hold, in other words.
This is how much you
can holding in a byte.
AUDIENCE: Why do you minus 1?
PROFESSOR: Ya, minus 1.
There's a minus 1 here,
and there's a minus 1 here,
but I can't find it
here, so roughly this.
But there is an overflow.
AUDIENCE: But where did
you get the minus 1 from?
PROFESSOR: Where do
you get the-- so,
this is how much you
can hold in a byte.
Byte has 8 bits, right?
From 0 0 to F F. This is
2 to the eighth minus 1.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
multiplication?
There is an overflow.
I don't have to deal with that.
You guys have to figure
out how to deal with it.
How about division?
What can you divide?
AUDIENCE: Some words?
PROFESSOR: Almost.
AUDIENCE: Words like--
PROFESSOR: A word
divided by a byte.
What do you get out of it?
AUDIENCE: Words?
PROFESSOR: That would be nice.
Nope.
Sorry, you get a byte.
And if you do module,
you also get a byte.
What if there's overflow
in the division?
What happens?
What would you expect to happen?
AUDIENCE: We don't have any
best flowing point numbers,
so, we shouldn't
get overflow, right?
PROFESSOR: How about 2 to
the 16 minus 1 divided by 1?
So what do get?
AUDIENCE: Same thing?
PROFESSOR: Will this
fit in the byte?
AUDIENCE: Yes?
No.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, that time I
don't get a word.
PROFESSOR: You don't get a word.
I promise you get a byte.
What will that byte be?
AUDIENCE: It's going
to be modulo something.
Most significant--
PROFESSOR: That's
reasonable, right?
Modulo to 56 because
that's what it can carry.
What about modulo?
What happens there
if you get overflow?
AUDIENCE: The same thing.
It's just going to loop, right?
0?
PROFESSOR: So if
you do a modulo,
this is going to be,
at most, 255 right?
If you do modulo
255, the remainder
is going to be
between 0 and 254.
Will that ever overflow byte?
No overflow.
No need to worry about it.
Word addition can overflow.
Subtraction can overflow.
Multiplication doesn't overflow.
Division overflows,
modulo doesn't.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean, like
will it see the space confined?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It sees the space of the result.
Because here, if you're
adding two words,
the result exceeds
the space of a word.
Which is what you get.
AUDIENCE: Is it just in all
cases it's just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So the reason you have to
deal with this weird system
is this is, pretty much, how
Intel does their arithmetic.
If you look at old school,
16-bit Intel processors,
you have registers and you
have exactly these operations.
For newer processors, there are
32 bits, but then it's just,
you write more F's on the board
and you get the same thing.
AUDIENCE: Is it most significant
bit, or most significant byte?
PROFESSOR: Most
significant byte.
On a real processor,
you have registers
that are the size
of a word and then
you can pull out the
bytes in constant time.
What constant do we have?
These are the operations.
What constants do we have?
Only two constants, 0 and 1.
What if you want to
get something bigger?
What if you want to get 2?
How do you get 2?
AUDIENCE: Two 1's?
1 plus 1?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
What if you want
to get this number?
AUDIENCE: Do that several times?
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It's kind
of painful to type,
even if you copy paste.
There's a method on
Word called from-bytes.
And it takes an M,
S, B and an L, S, B
and it gives you a word.
So what would I give it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's give it
a 1 and let's give it a 0.
So this will get 1,
0, 0 and then minus 1.
Yes?
OK.
Intel is pretty nice
about constants,
but some other
processors aren't.
So I figured, why not
let's get you acquainted
to these kind of tricks, to too.
Let's make the PSETS
more interesting.
All right, so any questions
on this fake processor
that you have to code for?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
the last one again?
PROFESSOR: Here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Word from-bytes.
PROFESSOR: So in Word
from-bytes a word is 2 bytes.
One next to the other.
It gives you the first byte,
and gives you the second byte.
In this case, the
first byte is 1.
The second byte is 0.
Right?
So 2 bytes.
A 1 and a 0.
How do you write this in hex?
1, 0, 0.
One byte, second byte.
And then I subtract
1 and I get this.
While I erase the
board, I want you guys
to think of graph
questions because this
is the other topic
we're looking at today.
What was unclear
about the lecture?
What is unclear about
graphs in general?
Do guys remember the
handshaking lemma?
What does it mean?
How do you prove it?
Things of that sort.
What do you guys
want to cover today?
AUDIENCE: Handshaking,
that's the thing where
you have a bunch nodes
and they're all connected,
like they're all in a closed
graph, that the number of edges
is equal to twice the
number of vertices?
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: That's
all it is, right?
PROFESSOR: The
number of vertices?
No.
AUDIENCE: The
number of handshakes
that occurred are twice
the number of edges.
You said the number
of vertices, wait--
PROFESSOR: No, vertices and
edges are not related in here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, think
of a triangle, right?
That's three edges,
three vertices.
Which is like not two times,
which is what you said.
It's the number of degrees
is twice the number of edges.
That's what I was
thinking of then.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
let's start with simple stuff.
What's a graph?
AUDIENCE: Nodes and edges?
PROFESSOR: All right.
Fancy word for nodes?
AUDIENCE: Vertex.
PROFESSOR: Vertex.
Vertices and edges.
How do I draw vertices?
How do I draw edges?
AUDIENCE: Circles and lines.
PROFESSOR: Circles and lines.
AUDIENCE: 0's and 1's.
Possibly arrows.
PROFESSOR: Possibly arrows.
I like that.
You want to get fancy.
[LAUGHTER}
PROFESSOR: When do I
draw an edge as a line?
When do I draw it as an arrow?
AUDIENCE: Directed under.
PROFESSOR: Which one's which?
AUDIENCE: Directed as an arrow.
Character number.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
Let's draw this graph here.
Yeah, looks like a
pretty boring graph.
Is this graph connected or not?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: What's
a connected graph?
AUDIENCE: I think
that we can get
to any other node
following some path.
PROFESSOR: There's a path
from any to any other node.
How do I make this
unconnected using
the least amount of effort?
It's a bit of a trick question.
Any guess is fine.
AUDIENCE: What was
the question again?
PROFESSOR: How do I
make this unconnected
using the least amount
of effort on my behalf?
AUDIENCE: Just add a node?
PROFESSOR: I heard
you move pages.
I don't like you racing
because I don't like the-- So
I like that answer out
of the two I heard.
Now it's not a connected graph.
How many connected
component does it have?
Two and five.
AUDIENCE: Or one
connected component,
but there are two components?
PROFESSOR: OK, what's
a connected component?
AUDIENCE: It's like in that part
of the graph the neck follows
the prognito beacon and puts
them in two parts [INAUDIBLE]
two connected components--
PROFESSOR: So, a
connected component
is a bunch of vertices such
that you can get from one vertex
to all the other vertices.
If the graph is
undirected, that's
true for any vertex in the set.
We also want the
sets to be maximal
because, if we say this
is a connected component,
it's not very useful.
Noticing that this whole
thing is a connected component
is useful.
So this is one component.
This is the other component.
Make sense?
So, we have the world.
We have cities.
You can bike from a city to
another city and that's it.
No other a route
of transportation.
How many connected components?
AUDIENCE: Seven?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Roughly seven.
Why?
OK, so it only seven?
AUDIENCE: Seven continents?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's say roughly seven.
So this is what I wanted.
I wanted some thinking.
If you try to get from a
continent to another continent,
presumably you'd go
through some patch of sea.
Otherwise, why are they
calling them continents?
Does anyone want to
give out another answer?
I asked this in the
previous section
and some people there give
me some very precise answers
that are not continents.
This is what I had
in mind, by the way.
As far as I'm concerned,
this is a good answer.
Come on guys, world.
Two things, islands and
Europe and Asia are connected,
so you can go from
one to the other.
They're weird.
Why are they
separate continents?
I have no idea.
The geography people might--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: You roll mountains?
PROFESSOR: OK, so it would
be a pain bike through them,
but presumably you can.
If you have a robot that
doesn't get tired or something
you can bike.
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
mind falling off cliffs.
PROFESSOR: The answer,
depending on my geography,
we know is somewhere
between 7 and 10,000,
or whatever the
number of islands is.
There are a lot of tiny
island somewhere, right?
Anyways, between seven
and a big number.
These are connected
components in the world.
What's the degree of A?
2.
What's the degree of the D?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Very good.
Let's make this.
The degrees of F,
G, H are 2, 2, 2.
The degree of C is 2.
The degree of B is?
AUDIENCE: --2.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
And the degree of E is?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: If you add up all
these numbers together what
you get?
18.
I can't do math, so
I couldn't possibly
have added all these
numbers together, right?
I used something else.
How many edges do I
have in the graph?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Do you see your connection here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: This is
the handshaking lemma.
That's all there is to it.
So if you look at
the degrees of a node
each edge adds one
to two degrees.
For instance, this edge
adds one to C's degree
and adds one to D's degree.
If you're a math person
and you write this up,
you have to write sums.
You have big sums using
intimidating notation,
so it's not as obvious.
But this is really
all there is to it.
Each edge contributes
one to two nodes degrees.
If you add up all
the degrees, you're
going to get to times
the number of edges.
So far so good?
What if we have directed graphs?
What if I had this?
A, B, C, D, E, F. What
is the degree of A?
AUDIENCE: 2?
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
Sorry, that was trick question.
A doesn't have a degree.
If you have directed graphs,
you don't have degrees.
You have in degrees
and out degrees.
Now that I've said that
you have no idea, right?
What's the out degree of A?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sometimes this is
known as the degree of edges.
This is 2.
What's the in degree of A?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So A has two edges
going out, 0 edges going in.
How about D?
What's the out degree of D?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Come on guys.
Don't scare me. (LAUGHS)
What's the in degree of D?
AUDIENCE: 2?
PROFESSOR: 2, very good.
PROFESSOR: So what's
the equivalent
of the handshaking lemma
on oriented graphs?
AUDIENCE: The sum of the
in degrees and out degrees?
PROFESSOR: OK, what about them?
AUDIENCE: They're equal to
twice the number of vertices?
PROFESSOR: Not quite.
They're equal to?
You had 80 percent
of the answer.
AUDIENCE: Oh. (LAUGHS)
PROFESSOR: So the sum of the in
degrees and the sum of the out
degrees.
AUDIENCE: So add them up?
PROFESSOR: If you
add them up, you
will get two times
the number of edges.
That is correct.
But, I want something more--
AUDIENCE: They equal each other?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
This is cooler, right?
So why is that?
Does anyone see why
that's the case?
Each edge-- Come on, guys.
So what does each edge do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So if I
look at this edge here,
this edge is going to
contribute 1 to B's out degree,
and 1 to D's in degree.
Each edge contributes
1 to an out degree
and 1 to an in degree.
That means that total
sum of out degrees
equals the total
sum of in degrees.
Both of them are E and
they combined to E. Sorry,
eyed I don't know why that
didn't click to me right away.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: The
intuition behind this
is, that for every node,
if you take an edge
you're going to
get somewhere else.
If the sum of the out
degrees was bigger,
then you have a
black hole somewhere.
If you go on an edge
you don't come back.
Same four in degrees.
OK, how do we represent graphs?
AUDIENCE: I think we just did.
PROFESSOR: Sure, if
you're drawing them
on the board that's what
you do, but if you're
in Python what do you do?
AUDIENCE: You can
have a link list.
PROFESSOR: Of?
AUDIENCE: Of each node having
its neighbors linked with.
PROFESSOR: OK, so I
have one big link list?
Or how does this work?
AUDIENCE: You'd have a
starting point of some sort.
A starting node.
Then from that node you can have
its neighbors connected to it.
So it was a link list , I guess.
PROFESSOR: I wasn't precise.
That is not trivial to build.
By the time we build that we're
done with this recitation.
What do you get is the
vertices and the edges.
We want an easier representation
that just looks at the vertices
and build something,
then looks at the edges
and builds something.
AUDIENCE: You could
have a table of values.
Like, A has these
neighbors-- a dictionary.
PROFESSOR: Let's go for that.
So we have a dictionary.
For each vertex
you have the list
of vertices that
are connected to it.
What's the list for A?
AUDIENCE: B and C?
PROFESSOR: OK, what's
the list for B?
AUDIENCE: A, D, and E.
PROFESSOR: All right.
For Python this would
be a dictionary, right?
So how much total
space does this take?
AUDIENCE: The number of nodes?
PROFESSOR: The number of--
AUDIENCE: --nodes.
Well, then there's also the
space you made for the list,
though.
PROFESSOR: If these were
actual slots in an array--
so this would be an array-- I
would have the number of nodes.
You're giving away the
answer to my next question.
So I have these slots here.
This would be an array.
It's order V just to store this.
The thing in Python is that
have these dictionaries that
are fancy hashes where
they grow as you need them.
For example, you
have 10,000 vertices
but you don't have any edge.
Your dictionary size is going
to be order 1 because it only
grows as you add edges to it.
So this is assuming that
I don't store empty lists.
If I have a stray
node here, if I
have a node I-- say this is
I-- if I don't store anything,
I don't have to pay for it.
If I store an empty list here,
then I have to pay for it.
There is an order V
component that you mentioned.
AUDIENCE: Let's say, if
there's a graph there,
everything is not connected
so there are a bunch of words
instead.
Then in that case it
would be order V, right?
PROFESSOR: It's order V
if we store empty lists
for the nodes that
don't have edges.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And if none of the
nodes have edges,
they're all unconnected--
PROFESSOR: On the other hand,
if I don't store anything
for the nodes that don't
have edges, it's order 1.
AUDIENCE: If you get no
edges do we do an empty list
or do we not store it?
PROFESSOR: Depends
on what you want.
So if we store
empty lists you're
going to have an
order V cost here.
But your code is going to
be simpler, presumably,
because you don't have
to check if something
is or isn't in the dictionary.
How about this stuff?
What's the total size
of this stuff here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Order E. How many elements
do I have in here in total?
In this thing here.
So what's the sum of
the length of the lists?
AUDIENCE: Average value of E
times the number of vertices?
PROFESSOR: Let's go
over something else.
AUDIENCE: The degree--
PROFESSOR: All right.
That's what I wanted to hear.
A lists its neighbors, right?
The number of neighbors that
A has is the degree of A. B
lists its neighbors, so
this is the degree of B.
If you sum up over all of them,
what is the sum of all the
agrees in the graph?
AUDIENCE: 2, E.
PROFESSOR: 2, E. We
learned about this, right?
The handshaking
lemma, 2, E. So what
is the total cost for
storing this data structure?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So V plus E,
assuming empty lists.
Let's look at another
data structure
for storing things in a graph.
So instead of using
lists, let's use a matrix.
A, B, C, D, E on top, and
A, B, C, D, E on the left.
Let's pretend our graph is
just that component over there.
Otherwise, it just gets big
and there's no extraneous site.
Does anyone know
how this is called?
If I put numbers
here, does anyone
know what this is called?
AUDIENCE: Is that a matrix?
PROFESSOR: There's
a fancy name for it.
It ends with matrix.
OK.
I don't think we taught
it to you, so don't worry.
The fancy name is maybe it's
misspelled, but something
that looks and sounds like
this., adjacency matrix.
Misspelled?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I hope
someone will help me.
OK so if this is an
adjacency matrix,
what should this element
between B and A tell me?
If it's an adjacency
matrix, it better
tell me if they're adjacent.
They're adjacent if they
have an edge between them.
For A and B, what
does it happen to be?
AUDIENCE: One?
PROFESSOR: OK.
A and A?
What do we do?
AUDIENCE: What with 1?
It's adjacent to itself.
PROFESSOR: What's
easier for the algorithm
that you're trying to implement?
AUDIENCE: 1?
PROFESSOR: So it
doesn't really matter.
We use 1's most of the
time, but sometimes it's
easier to use a 0.
AUDIENCE: Then you can
get to A from A, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's why you'd use a 1.
Sometimes, though, you
don't want to in code.
So someone dictate this to me.
Or, everyone dictate this to
me so I know it makes sense.
A and C, is there an
edge between them?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: What do I write?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: A and D?
A and E?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: B, A?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: B, C?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: B, D?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: The E?
PROFESSOR: OK.
C, A?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: C, B?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: C, D?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: C, E?
AUDIENCE: 0.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Now I'm going to
use the bits you
gave me to come to get this.
Let's see if I can
do it correctly.
And D?
I'm not looking at the graph,
by the way, I'm trusting you.
So you better give
me the right answer.
D?
AUDIENCE: 1.
PROFESSOR: How many
1's do I have in this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: To see if
you guys are thinking.
AUDIENCE: 2, E? [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Each edge
contributes to two 1's, right?
And that accounts
for most of the 1's.
AUDIENCE: O plus V.
PROFESSOR: So this is
how many 1's I have.
How many 0's do I have?
AUDIENCE: V squared
minus 2, E plus V?
PROFESSOR: This is
a non-boring way
of asking how many elements
I have in this matrix.
This is what I was looking for.
So V columns, right?
Zeros V squared's
total elements.
How much memory do I
need to store this?
AUDIENCE: V squared.
PROFESSOR: V squared. what?
If I want to store it as
compactly as possible?
I want to pack these
as tight as I can.
AUDIENCE: You mean you need
the entire array arranged?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so
what do I store?
V squared what?
AUDIENCE: Oh, you mean units.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
What's the unit?
AUDIENCE: 1 bit?
PROFESSOR: All right!
So V squared bits Whereas,
this is V plus E words
because you have to store
pointers everywhere here.
So sometimes if your
graph is really dense
you might prefer
this representation.
Let me see, how much do I have?
Oh, plenty of time.
Who remembers
breadth-first search?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Basically you
just start at some node
and you check all its neighbors,
and check all those neighbors.
PROFESSOR: All right.
In breadth-first
search we have a graph.
What did I draw there?
A. B, E. So suppose
this is our graph.
And I do a breadth-first
search starting at A.
How does that work?
I started with the list of the
nodes that I'm going to visit.
I initialization it with A
because this is the only node
that I know about.
What happens next?
AUDIENCE: It goes with B and C.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So I take out of the list
the first thing that I can.
This is my current node.
You said I visit B and C
because they're the neighbors.
Right.
I took A out of the list.
A was definitely visited.
And I'm visiting B and C. What
do I do when I visit them?
AUDIENCE: Put them in the list.
PROFESSOR: Put them in the list.
This means I discovered them and
I'm going to visit the later.
So I discovered them and
I know of their existence.
What happens next?
AUDIENCE: Check if
B is what you want.
PROFESSOR: So B gets out of
the list, and what do I do?
AUDIENCE: Discover
it's neighbors.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so its neighborhoods
are A, B, and E. What Now?
AUDIENCE: If they
haven't already
been on that list then
add a [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A was
already visited.
D and E weren't.
D and E, then what happens?
AUDIENCE: Then you
check C's neighbors.
PROFESSOR: Any neighbor's
that I haven't seen?
Nope.
Then?
AUDIENCE: D?
AUDIENCE: D and?
AUDIENCE: E.
PROFESSOR:OK.
And then?
PROFESSOR: I guess
you could go to F,
but it's not
connected to anything.
But how did you
get A then, right?
PROFESSOR: So A
is the first node.
I started with A
because I said I'm
doing a breadth-first
search starting from A.
So BFS starts from somewhere.
A BFS has a source.
We'll see why that
matters in a bit.
So you ever get to see F?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: Nope.
So if I start at A what
are the nodes that I visit
and what are the nodes
that I don't visit?
AUDIENCE: Well you visit all
the ones in the connected graph.
PROFESSOR: All right, in
the connected component.
So the whole graph can be
connected or not connected.
The nodes that I
visit are the nodes
in A's connected component
because, by definition, those
are the nodes that
I can reach from A.
If I have many kind
of the components
and I use BFS starting
from one node,
I might not visit
the entire graph.
How do I keep track of what
node that I've discovered
and haven't discovered?
What data structure do I
use for these smiley faces?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR:So for
the smiley faces.
For this thing I
probably want a queue.
We'd teach you
something simpler,
but most of the time when
you write the code you
actually use queue.
What do I want for
the smiley faces?
When I pull a node out,
say I pulled out B,
and I see A, D, E, I want
to know that I visited A
and I didn't visit the D
and E. You guys remember
that we didn't visit D and E,
right, by the time we got to 2?
OK.
So I want to be able to check
whether I visited a node
or not really fast.
What data structure should
I use for the smileys?
AUDIENCE: A hash table.
PROFESSOR: A has table.
Cool.
What's a hash table in Python?
AUDIENCE: A dictionary.
PROFESSOR: A dictionary.
All right, so this is
going to be a seen, which
is a dictionary, and it
maps vertices to maybe true.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR:Yep.
Python has a set, right?
So you can use that.
The smileys needs to be
some sort of a dictionary.
So given that, and
assuming that this
is a queue that we
can extract and you
can start from in
constant time, what
is the running time of BFS?
Let's make life easy.
Let's assume the graph is
connected and let's assume just
doesn't exist.
BFS was the running time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] visiting.
PROFESSOR: So you
visit every node once,
so it's at least
V. That's a start.
Now what do you do when
you visit the node?
AUDIENCE: Check out all the--
PROFESSOR: All the
neighbors, right?
Given the node, you have
to go to the data structure
that you have that's
either this or this,
and you have to get
a list of neighbors.
If I have this data
structure, how fast
do I get a list of
neighbors for a node?
AUDIENCE: Order of the degree?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Order of the degree of the node.
That's good.
How about this data structure?
AUDIENCE: Same-- oh,
no that's order of V.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So in this data structure,
for example, C only
has two edges coming out of it.
But I have to go through the
entire lining of the matrix
to see where I have my 0's
and where I have my 1's.
In order to list the neighbors,
here is straight up order V,
whereas this is order of
the degree of the node
that I'm looking for.
So for this, where it's
nice and simple, order of V,
what is the total running time?
AUDIENCE: Wait, because
it's B plus B. Oh no, it's
the same one.
PROFESSOR: So for
each node I have to?
AUDIENCE: V squared.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we're up to V
squared already.
What else do we need to do?
Anything that they need to
do on a node is order of V,
so V squared is going to
be the total running time.
That's it.
So if we use an
adjacency matrix we
get order of V squared as
the total running time.
What about if we lists,
what the running time?
I'll give you a hint.
You have to use
amortized analysis.
Shivers anyone?
[LAUGHTER]
We know it's order
V because we're
going to visit every node.
And you guys didn't see what
I was going to write here.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
So for every node I go
through the neighbors
and I do something to them.
Right?
I check if they're in
seen, if not then I
add them to the list.
So for every node the work is?
AUDIENCE: it's degrees.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So if I look at all the nodes?
AUDIENCE: That's E.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
For every node I have
to look at its neighbors
and I have to see which
neighbors are in seen.
For the neighbors
that are not in seen
I have to add to my queue.
Checking if a neighbor is
in seen or not is order 1.
Adding it to the
queue is order 1.
So the total work
for a node is order
of neighbors because of the
adjacency list, not matrix.
If I look at the
entire graph, here I
can't do a local analysis
like I did before.
If I look at the entire graph
and I look at all the nodes
slash vertices,
then the total work
is the sum of their degrees.
For each node is degree.
For total work,
sum of the degrees.
And I have that nice
handshaking lemma
that says that the sum
of the degrees is 2,
E. So order E. So
total running time?
V plus E.
OK, can I say that the
running time is order E?
With no V's?
AUDIENCE: No, because you
have to look at every--
PROFESSOR: Is it?
AUDIENCE: V greater
than [INAUDIBLE]
in case of not
connected components?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: It's
possible that you could
have more vertices than edges--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So it's possible that I have
more vertices than edges.
I agree with that, but I
do anything to the vertices
that I haven't seen?
So this is subtle.
The difference
between this and this
is a matter of how you
implement everything.
In CLRS they assume that
the seen is an array.
So all of their nodes
have numbers from 1 to V.
So then they initialize an
array, everything is false,
and then they set
the true elements.
In Python we can
use a dictionary
and not initialize
it with anything.
So if you do it that way in
Python and code carefully,
you can get to order E.
The parts of the graph
that you don't discover, you
don't have to pay for them.
If you look at CLRS
code, it is definitely
V plus E. The difference
between this and this
depends on the code.
What's the point
of BFS, by the way?
Why do we care?
What does it give us?
AUDIENCE: The
shortest word path.
PROFESSOR:The shortest
path from point?
AUDIENCE: From your start
to where you're going.
PROFESSOR:So it gives you the
shortest path from the node
that I'm starting the BFS from.
So only from this node?
If I start BFS at A
it's going to give me
the length of the shortest
path from A to which node?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All the nodes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: All
the nodes that are
visited by BFS are reachable
and we have a path from them.
How do you compute
this distance?
Let's see, so what's the
distance from A to A?
AUDIENCE: 0?
PROFESSOR: 0.
When I start from A and I see
that its neighbors are B and C,
what's the distance from
A to B and from A to C?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now I look at B. What's the
distance between A and A?
A is B's neighbor.
AUDIENCE: With A and A?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I have three neighbors.
B has three neighbors,
A, D, and E.
So I care about the distances
between A and A, D, E. Distance
A, A, distance A, D, and
distance A, E. This one is 0.
How about the distances
between A and D and A and E?
They're 2.
So the way I would
compute these distances
is that I start with A being 0.
The distance from A to A is 0.
And then when I look at a node,
when I discover the neighbors,
all the neighbors that don't
have smiley faces on them
get the node's distance plus 1.
You can get to them by
getting in the current node
and then traversing an edge.
When you do that it's
important that you don't update
the distances of the nodes
that have smiley faces.
If you do, you're going to say
that the distance from A to A
is 2 and all hell
breaks lose from there.
AUDIENCE: Wait, why would
you say it would be 2?
PROFESSOR: If I forget the
fact that it has a smiley face.
So if I go through
all these neighbors
and I say the
distance from A to B
is one then the distance from
A to all of B's neighbors
has to be 2.
That would be wrong.
AUDIENCE: Wait,
from A to all of--
PROFESSOR: B's neighbors.
AUDIENCE: From A to all of--
Oh, because A is one Of--
PROFESSOR: B's neighbors.
AUDIENCE: Yeah OK.
PROFESSOR: The
smileys tell me which
vertices I've already
seen and I've already,
presumably computed
distances for them.
We don't want to update those.
OK this is BFS in essence.
One question.
Between Facebook and
Twitter, which one's directed
and which one's undirected?
AUDIENCE: Facebook
is undirected.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Facebook is undirected.
Why is it undirected?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: When you follow
someone they don't necessarily
follow you.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this is Twitter, right?
Twitter, directed
because of follows.
Has anyone used
Facebook recently?
Did you guys see
there's a new option?
AUDIENCE: The little
scroll bar on the side?
PROFESSOR: Subscribers.
AUDIENCE: Oh, ya.
PROFESSOR: OK, so how
do subscribers work?
AUDIENCE: You subscribe.
It's like google plus.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK.
Directed are undirected?
If I subscribe to you do
you have to subscribe to me?
AUDIENCE: Directed.
PROFESSOR: So which one is it?
AUDIENCE: I guess Facebook
is kind of directed now
because you can
unsubscribe from people.
PROFESSOR: Is it?
So Facebook has
two graphs in it.
They happen to have
the same vertices.
The people are the
vertices in both graphs.
But the friends relationship
defines an undirected graph.
The subscribers relationship
defines a directed graph.
The graphs are
completely different.
And there are two graphs.
That's the right way
to reason about them.
that's why it was
slightly tricky.
Can someone think of a cool
way to use BFS on Facebook?
AUDIENCE: That's
networks, right?
Figuring out how many people
are in the first degree
or second degree.
MySpace was really into that.
PROFESSOR: Lincoln
also does that, right?
How many people
are your friends?
How many people are
your friend's friends?
So and so forth.
Now suppose you want to
get to someone in Facebook
and you don't know
them directly.
They're not your friends.
Presumably, you
want to get to them
through the minimum
amount of effort.
So you want to see do you
have a friend that knows them?
If not, do you
have a friend that
knows a friend that knows them?
Do you have a friend
that knows a friend that
knows a friend that knows them?
So and so forth.
So BFS will give you
that minimum path.
OK.
do the graphs make sense?
So by the way, the
BFS on Facebook
is just the beginning
of a ton of cool things
you can with graph algorithms.